[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want you
know what I saw yesterday that was high
larious a carne asada talking to you
know that's pretty funny it's not
catcalling I haven't seen a cat haul in
a long weird a Mexican neighborhood I
was in South Pasadena what yeah South
Pasadena and you know there's like a
little white cat calling no no there's
like a few like homeless people out
there only wipe you this dude was
[ __ ] wild man like so you know that
Cheesecake Factory on Colorado yes so
there's a girl in front of it I hope she
watches this cuz it was so funny and she
was wearing like short shorts and like a
crop top and she had that cute little
you know baby backpack that girls wear
oh yeah it's on her cell phone texting
and this dude got some good details on
the girl
yep she was pretty cute so he's walking
upright so this is the girly girls
[Music]
what's up with your name I see you
tagged in this [ __ ] cold as ice Asian
huh no she's Mexican
oh we're used to that you know this
wasn't even face he was circling around
like a vulture circling she yep amazing
dude I know cat call is annoying to
girls but those fools have a lot of
confidence they do a sky and I wish I
had that confidence back in the day we
wish the guys are crazy about guys guys
are so [ __ ] cop he's homeless
I'm talking about dignity to lose and
I'm not assuming he's homeless he has
the whole cardboard thing with him to
give me money think you know what else
we saw that was funny in Pasadena so
there was so we were at a red
we were waiting across the street so
we're standing there we just hear this
flew just [ __ ] jet like a person on a
fluid jam and the [ __ ] out like order
was it a recorder it wasn't even a flute
no all right that was a recorder and
then something looking around and
there's this dude in an element with all
the windows down I'm Way better than him
he was pretty good I thought I thought
he was sending me that video to make fun
of me because I have a Honda Element and
there's a guy like that driving that car
he's making fun of two people I'd let
you pull dinner from the internet video
yeah we're just walking down the street
on that what the hell cuz it's some [ __ ]
that like that belongs on the Internet
and you would never see in person you
know so we were there and I was like why
but y'all kept it for yourself
yep uh I'm not like that I'll put
anything on my story I walked by and I
see something funny oh yeah you better
shovel because you're good at
instagramming I'm not good I don't even
remember that stories exist after time
hmm I only do the regular posts because
that's the only button I see it's at the
bottom you know my story whenever I want
to talk [ __ ] something happens I'll be
on there with my puppy filter on my good
evening everyone
[Laughter]
news broadcast stupid story one day and
she devious she was like would you like
to be on JK news and I was like yes I
would
now we all got to have the puppy filters
while we talk it does yeah and people
act like it doesn't like change anything
they're like no what did you expect me
to just have like puppy ears on when you
met me like know it like smoothes your
face out it changes your jawline it
shows everything your eyes are bigger
yes yes with you didn't know that with
the puppy filter like I am [ __ ] cute
I thought I was always that cute dude it
makes you wake you makes you Shooter
mm-hmm your eyes bigger and she's
[ __ ] weird dude the [ __ ] poster
that girls always do is [ __ ] weird to
me I'm like what's wrong weird about it
what's wrong with her like what's wrong
with your leg Euler face I'd do it to
everything well I don't think they're I
think you're being a negative about it I
think it's just fun I don't think it's
just fun I think girls do it because
they think it makes them look better and
theirs but it really does though I don't
love myself yeah but you guys shakers
you guys look fine so it's like when I
see that I'm like what why why you hide
your face like what's wrong with it what
a kind man I don't know when girls put
on bunny ears it's even hotter he makes
a compliment sound like a disco right no
it sounds like a compliment it I
literally said you look perfect the way
you are use low self-esteem [ __ ]
there you go but in like inside we're
all thinking like but you don't know
what I look like without that filter you
say that but you don't know I see it oh
I've seen like the no filter face and it
looks fantastic that was somebody say
that to me that sounds positive I want
to hear that no you don't need a [ __ ] oh
we don't there's it's a little different
our skin is terrible I know it is great
just bought me face wash clay wash
[ __ ] [ __ ] eucalyptus tree [ __ ]
thing a tea tree [ __ ] wipe thing
would you use any of it [ __ ] dude like
once already
no I you know what you need to do though
is immediately after you [ __ ] workout
rinse that [ __ ] cuz I leave that
[ __ ] on for a whole day and by the time
yeah
rose all this smog and dirt and darkness
sticking and it just sticks to her face
and even after a shower I'll do that
[ __ ] die beauty dab dab and then do
this and I'll still have darkness come
out yeah people coming out your face boy
oil change a complete face oil change
but I love when my face is driest but I
hate that [ __ ] feels great I like when I
smile his cracks what in the [ __ ] that's
the worst feeling on earth he smiles and
it's like ash and then it's white like
he looks like death like he just saw the
coast cuz when I moisturize I feel I
feel greasy
I like being dry did you got it you have
all these wrinkles now like on the side
of your feet I use a scrub dude if your
face is like ashy and white then you
have a lot of dead skin no I scrub the
[ __ ] out of my face don't tell him to
scrub and then you have to moisturize
bro I use hemp lotion that's why my skin
so doing Elsa mm-hmm what do you smell
like weed nice didn't know I'd use I
don't know hemp lotion is like that
hippie ass organic [ __ ] because I've had
sensitive I used to never care about
like my skin stuff until Mary all called
me hideous so for her she like she
wouldn't notice all the the thing is you
don't know how ugly you are until you
get a girlfriend exactly yeah I had
that's a hell of ecstasy and my [ __ ]
skin broke the [ __ ] out like an early
college I had baby skin and then I went
on like a two-year f2c binge and then my
face
I had like pimples on top of pimples Oh
like I look like a appear at the beach
full of barnacles sometimes when I see
that skin I feel like I want to get a
lighter and just [ __ ] roast it a
little bit and then a new skin will grow
I did that cuz you have a lighter no I
heat it up a spoon on the stove cuz I'm
like these [ __ ] things won't go away
I tried scrub in I tried even you can
still know what don't move past that why
would you like a hot spoon and put it to
your face cuz baby talk today
what you would like why don't you shave
it off you i tried shaving
you would rather have a face like a
stage Firebird what are you calling it I
don't know I just I got like uh stage
fright so the backside of a spoon and I
heated it cuz I thought you want to [ __ ]
with me [ __ ] pimple yeah if I was
your dad and I walked into your room and
I saw you look at the mirror heat up a
[ __ ] spoon and not smoke crack and
put it to your face I'd be mad at you
drunk [ __ ] ass pimple oh my god
I just told you is so mad about it okay
one time when I was a kid I had a really
bad mosquito bite and I cut it open with
a razor cuz it hurts so bad I done that
stuff too because I don't know why I
don't know I don't know why I thought it
would help that's true you want to give
it more yeah now you press it so hard
you could make an X with it does that
[ __ ] that's it we get it
your family's [ __ ] crazy the whole
family I don't spit on it
if you guys want good skit though you
gotta have a good diet that's true it's
all about that terrible acne like a year
ago and like now my skin is all [ __ ]
up still but I'll have acne anymore I
have to stop eating coffee red meat
dairy and soy yeah
equal less it's like wow oh my god yeah
okay cool yeah take ecstasy it'll [ __ ]
your skin good on that I did a lot of
ecstasy but I did it [ __ ] I didn't get
no acne though it might be a hormonal
right it might be might be genetic I
just change this whole reality look if
my presence started me yet baby's skin
to and he started taking his skin got
[ __ ] up he also wasn't sleeping and he
was partying like crazy but his skin was
still smooth until I came to America
because he was partying a lot no he was
a party back then and it was still
smooth
and then you start taking XE I think
there's so many toxins just [ __ ] your
[ __ ] up I think because I could do like
a before and after picture of my skin
from like four months ago till now it's
like 180 it's like yeah better skin now
David you are glowing thank you very
like dewy he's pregnant there's two
things know so it's like diet a whole
bunch of water boil water drink a lot of
[ __ ] water I drink a lot of water now
and it's hard to cuz like skin regimen
is [ __ ] not everybody else's stuff works
for yours so it's like literally a solid
should a [ __ ] three month process and
then you keep my skin radioactive
microwave - [ __ ] for my skin seller in
the car [ __ ] these [ __ ]
I even tried getting like a cotton swab
and soaking it in just disinfectant
right so I would put that and I put it
right here and I'll get duct tape so it
doesn't move cuz I'm gonna roll around
at night Wow damn didn't I made it worse
man no they had the internet dude uh
there was it was like it was like 56k
back then yeah you don't trust the [ __ ]
you read are you know in p-diddy going
oh I had bad skin Proactiv kid on my ear
[ __ ] lying sack of [ __ ] did he
but you said you had Proactiv I try -
yeah yeah I had the subscription did it
work yeah I think if I use it
you know the three-step process you
gotta wash your face anybody's told
they'd rather just burn a spoon I tried
it for like two or three weeks and it
would help out and then online Manish
that's taken a long time cuz cuz I get
hot too so as I'm putting on the toner
like the side that I they put on when
I'm lifted this side I'm already
sweating that [ __ ] out Wow and then by
the time I put the lotion on I'm
sweating the lotion out so I just listen
up come on my face when I go okay hold
on but it worked it did work actually we
are you're talking [ __ ] and now I don't
even know but it works but you look like
you have to come on your face and you
rather get a box full of leeches and
[ __ ] stick it all over your face [ __ ]
Proactiv works but it's so tedious let
me just get a bottle of sriracha it's
run that [ __ ] oh yeah your tedious the
tedious stuff is not even that t is to
lighting us food on fire and putting it
on your face dude I hate sweating you
won't what do you mean so like so this
is what happens right so toner is a
cleanser right there's a ball oh no but
with this motion I can find do this for
30 seconds I'm gonna start sweating
yeah but either when you're gonna sweat
and then after you put the lotion on you
think it's greasy right you gotta let it
chill for like ten minutes and then it
absorbs into your skin and then it's dry
it is not even oily at all like I put it
on his face is like a song I know why he
sweats though he probably rubs off [ __ ]
of us he's like he's giving himself a
[ __ ] face massage with the [ __ ]
with that cotton thing I think I think I
am yeah the pad thing the [ __ ] Circle
Circle pads I don't know we get you
though yeah the little oh you come up a
little okay no Chad the pad how much
pressure do you plan on your face when
you do it I keep going until there's no
more until it's still white the cotton
balls white it's like wiping your ass
that's too hard bro do you wipe their
ass that way where you sew your finger
rips through the paper and you [ __ ]
no I don't you single wiping is that so
hard that his [ __ ] finger goes
through like this I feel like you like
what you wipe your face like when people
squeegee their car windows yes
everything his teeth his [ __ ] car he
doesn't want contact me more but if he
has an itch that's happening mm-hmm the
way he washes butthole he says he goes
in and he hooks it every day
dude I'm legit think that your [ __ ]
has no wrinkles now like it's just like
smooth with the friction and yeah like
your poop just comes out like spaghetti
that's the way my grandma does it so I
was taught to wash my face with my
grandma oh my god boys I don't want to
hear your story though the one that we
forgot about a long time ago or are we
talking about the one we clear - my skin
doesn't matter these cucumbers I never
really had basket I feel bad even
wasting your guys's time so I'm just
gonna jump to it right after I had like
my skin cleared up moving on did it come
back no it's fine like I don't know when
you were pregnant you know was that mean
you saw it was never bad but I would
always have a break out here and there
but now I actually never notice oh
that's why it's not that bad but for
myself it was just you notice all your
flaws yeah everyone applause it's so
funny like you can't even see it until
you squint and you're like oh yeah I see
the pimple yeah I just said but I never
thought it was that bad oh you just
you're like look how [ __ ] up my
eyebrows are I'm like they look perfect
so that's a short way of me saying I
need to trim my eyebrows wait how do
y'all not notice this stuff okay what do
you all notice on women yeah that's
right
as women I think they just see tits
booty no no we don't know what it's
supposed to be like so if you ask us
does this look [ __ ] up like unless
it's really [ __ ] up you can't tell
like if you shave off one of her
eyebrows I'll probably notice these
dudes specifically we're not very like
look conscious so it for us like it's
just kind of like everyday stuff it's
like my face is clean my whatever we're
good yeah you know but I you know not
not all guys are like that like there's
a lot of YouTube dudes they'd they'd get
their eyebrows done critical of their
face of what they would understand I
knew I knew once if got a haircut yeah
yeah but that was a substantial change
you're talking about like they got all
my legs are kind of furry and in your
life I don't even see anything but
everything you've when you touch it it's
like oh yeah I have that all blessed
facility like in like whatever they
light like guys have that in hobbies
right like for example this is not a
hobby but I just got my car washed
yesterday yeah getting all the hard
water stains out right he goes hey man
I'm really sorry I was like what's up he
goes I couldn't get all the hard water
stains if you look at the top of your
hood you see like three spots right
there I was staring at it I was like see
it he goes I notice that's tight yeah
but the guy was like seriously upset
about it he goes I could usually get
them all out but I can't get these three
spots out I'm like dude you ruined his
home did you go
hey I can't tip you problems Oh honestly
bro you're a piece of [ __ ] you should
have been outraged Oh talk to your
manager right the [ __ ] now yeah it
bothered him though but that's like his
profession that's his [ __ ] yes his [ __ ]
I still don't see it today so I'm like
whatever it's fine but like he watched
my car so clean I didn't know I had
scratches on the car until like he
watched it but don't even notice [ __ ] on
you that you don't even know yeah we
have like wait do you guys have things
for females like if you notice that it's
like whew that's a deal-breaker like a
physical thing no but if they stank it's
game over
yeah smell is bad lard has it Bart has a
lot of those really a Mike much like
dirty hair like a
dirty hair that makes you look good yeah
yup it does we're not gonna have that
conversation on this video but David
knows she can tell when I get a haircut
to be fair as long as I know your hair
look the same every single time so you
guys don't know I got a haircut
Wow you guys don't know oh my god I feel
bad you don't notice you don't know
that's the Schillings anything different
[Laughter]
you notice the gradient in the fade it's
funny because okay seems like really
obsessed with his fitness right now like
he's trying to be like super like
especially cuz we're traveling so much
and we're going to like top tropical
places or whatever so he's like oh man
we're gonna have my shirt off I need to
make sure I look good that's time I
wonder what that feels like he's always
telling me like did I like manic I
gained so much weight from all that
eating that we just did like man I'm so
fat right like you look exactly at me
you know it's crazy I've never had like
like crazy like body image issues you
believed in me when we don't like take
off my shirt I'm in the wine I don't go
[ __ ] you know I mean so like those that
[ __ ] a feeling to have you don't mean
you'll grab his rolls the [ __ ] small
Indiana I'm so [ __ ] fat I am the only
the only thing that's affected me is
doing Muay Thai and not being able to do
stuff completely because of my weight
because it's a functional fitness to it
so it's like if I don't lose weight I
don't get physically stronger this guy's
gonna keep punching me in the face you
know and then it gets me to be like okay
I gotta lose weight I gotta I gotta get
my you know [ __ ] up yeah it's more
functional based exactly so I've never I
mean I do notice in the mirrors like uh
it doesn't feel good but I never went I
just wanna [ __ ] get a razor razor it
off okay you know what I want to do I
want to kill an exacto knife and cut it
and then get a spoon and scrape the fat
out
papaya well I stopped my Bart's body
before yeah
Halla body dysmorphia
[Music]